if you've been intimidated by arma in
the past or have fallen off the game
armor of forger now going into early
access is looking to hook you back in
with a smaller stand-alone experience
that the community can mod test and
change let's look at the good the bad
and if this game can capture a new
generation of arma players ahead of arma
4. arma led the way on military
simulation games for a long time with
countless scenarios great combined armed
big team battles and fantastic mods like
daisy that eventually evolved into games
like playerunknown's battlegrounds but
being very simulation based it was
always a game that was pretty tough for
general audiences to get into in more
recent times arm has seen pressure from
a host of other male sim titles like
squad insurgency sandstorm hell let
loose and rising storm just to name a
few those games tend to deliver a much
more honed experience that's far easier
to get into so is it time for a modern
arma game for a modern audience arma has
tried to slim down in the past he tried
project argo and now armorer forger is
looking to try again so there's good
news and bad news here the good news is
that armor or forger is a test bed for
arma 4. but the bad news is that arma 4
is still a ways off and not the army
game you'll get to play now in early
access armor or forger is a standalone
title that takes place on the island of
evron set in the 1980s but the location
is inspired by the former sovereign
state of czechoslovakia armor of forger
is releasing on both xbox and pc so mods
on pc will now work on xbox it's a game
that's looking to be a place for the
arma community to put the new infusion
engine to the test and hopefully work
out the kinks and bugs ahead of arma 4.
there are two multiplayer game modes
conflict and game master in conflict you
capture positions around the map and in
game master players take on more
specific combat scenarios and those can
be edited on the fly there's also a
workshop for people to start modding and
developing their own ideas so who is
arma reforger for i'm coming at this as
a battlefield and call of duty player
who's dabbled in milsim titles like
insurgency and rising storm but also
play games with massive player counts
like mag and planetside 2. arma is still
for people who really like hardcore
military simulation games that hasn't
really changed i mean it this is beyond
just needing a mic and a few friends
this is needing a large organized crew
of players as we experience playing a
few hours of conflict my first few
rounds were really just stumbling around
learning to navigate with a compass and
a map again then sorting out who i was
supposed to be shooting at and then
getting killed by things in the distance
which is very arma it took a while to
get acclimated to the game but again if
you're an avid arma player that probably
won't be too difficult for you for
better or worse like all games you play
with friends a lot of the fun comes down
to who you play with all right
once an experienced group jumped on the
server it was a whole different game it
had a pretty good time this group was
extremely organized like commanders
would go off to the side and hash out a
plan then team leaders wrangled us up
into squads and navigated us to
objectives if it went bad there was a
person back at headquarters who
organized respawning players back into
squads and sent them back out again with
more orders and that level of
coordination has always been the thing
that both makes arma like nothing else
and also a huge barrier for people who
are just trying to play or just trying
to learn and also a huge barrier that
can hold the game back moving forward
for a larger more mainstream audience
when it comes together there are amazing
moments where planning pays off and
everything just falls into place the
combat and arma yeah it's fun as hell
patrolling a road and getting into
contact or fending off waves of
counter-attacks or just the sheer volume
of outbound fire at times is truly
something
at one point my squad was killed right
next to me and i didn't even know they
were dead because it was night and their
comms just went silent then suddenly i
was surrounded by enemy forces who were
about as surprised as i was arma does a
great job of simulating that chaos
confusion and even boredom of war you'll
spend a lot of time just either standing
around and planning or traveling to
places with brief thrilling firefights
at the end you have to be okay with that
slower pace but there's a satisfaction
in the tension and the build up to these
moments where hopefully your planning
paid off it makes you realize the
constant action in games like call of
duty can feel hollow and kind of
pointless at times so if armor or forger
is so reliant on group play but wants to
pull in a larger audience and maybe pull
in those laps battlefield players it
might need to start adding more modern
conveniences like waypoint markers
contextual call out and ping systems and
a commander system that doesn't need
squads to physically talk to each other
that could massively lower the barrier
to entry i'm thinking about say the ping
system from apex the commander system
from battlefield 4 and just kind of like
all of what planetside 2 does it's hard
to see if armor or forger doesn't have
these things because they haven't been
put in it's early access or they're
there but buried in menus or the game
just trying to be authentic to an 80s
setting again we only spent a couple
hours with it and because of the mod
ability we might see these things appear
as time goes on but if you're used to
these modern gaming comforts this might
not be the title for you
another thing that's kind of always been
in arma is that simple actions are just
still somehow overly complicated in a
way that isn't the case in so many other
titles people struggle to figure out how
to spawn vehicles from menus start up a
humvee and drive it save a loadout and
figure out where to join a squad that
was buried a few menus deep again that
being said more veteran arma players on
our server were saying that they were
pleased with some of the quality of life
improvements so it does seem better if
you're familiar with the series already
another thing and i say this is someone
coming at the game who's played armor in
the past and also played games like pubg
but the grid inventory system just feels
outdated in a way that pulls you out of
the experience every time you have to
use it many modern games have simplified
these systems with classes or loadouts
or only needing to go into your
inventory for some things some of these
older design choices could make it less
likely that newcomers will stick around
when it comes to weapons the 80s theme
keeps things simple you won't find a lot
or any attachments so far and most
weapons only sport iron sights
fortunately arma does have a clever
trick which is when you long click the
mouse you can focus in on targets almost
like you have binoculars attached to
your eyes and if you then fast click the
mouse you'll transition to aiming down
sights that helps you see soldiers who
are far off which is usually the range
you'll be fighting at for those who want
an even closer look there was one
designated marksman rifle with a scope
that could be zeroed into different
ranges other than that weapons just
kinda were what they were you could grab
a variety of them from the base and head
out hoping you made the right choice
shooting feels very snappy and
controllable with the series usual
bullet physics and a lot of what you'd
be doing is suppressive fire anyway on
that note nothing grabs your attention
like that crack and whiz of enemy
bullets flying over your head as they
shoot back
when it came to the new game engine
itself i'm not an expert here but things
like lighting and water looked better to
my eyes the game was fairly stable
although still had plenty of glitches
like funky ground textures and sometimes
frame rate drops and let's just say that
nighttime was a little too
nighttime-ish like i get it night is
dark but from a gameplay perspective you
need to see what you're doing there are
compromises that can be made here my
squad stumbled around in the dark one
night for quite a while because while
you can turn on a flashlight and hold
the gun at the same time the flashlight
doesn't point in the same direction as
your weapon this is where modern
attachments and weapon lights can have a
positive impact on gameplay we didn't
have night vision goggles or anything
maybe that's something that could come
later when it came to the 80s theme some
things worked and some things didn't but
look that's the entire point of armor or
forger it's there to test and mod and
get the community involved in the
development of arma 4. so let us know
what you think of the comments below are
you a massive arma fan and see potential
here for a new generation of arma
players or are you someone who's never
played an army game before what would
get you into hardcore military sim
titles like this we cover a wide variety
of first person and third person
shooters so head on over to gamespot and
gamespot's youtube page heck we have a
modern warfare 2 coming up this year
thanks for watching